President Trump was at the Vatican
meeting Pope Francis he was meeting Pope
Francis yeah yeah thank you for trying
to be interested people were just barely
there like they thought up like cows
that were napping meeting the Pope this
is big right
during their meeting that's too much
during their meeting Pope Francis gave
President Trump a medal yeah yeah
then Melania said hey if anyone deserves
a medal here it's me all right
what kind of Melania impression with
yeah hey if anyone goes oh he's a medal
here it's me see I made her like Rocco
right no I don't do a Melania Trump
I didn't that's right that's right
president Trump was at the Vatican
meeting with Pope Francis the world
leader who believes himself the
embodiment of God on earth said he's a
big fan of the Pope really likes him
gotta think about that one for bit then
you like it that's available I'm gonna
write it out for everybody this is weird
while he was there President Trump gave
Pope Francis several books written by
Martin Luther King yeah that seems nice
then Trump said in my opinion what Trump
said in my opinion Kings best books were
the shining and Pet Sematary
yeah I'm just telling you what he said
my job during her visit to the Vatican
this morning Melania Trump were a black
dress and black veil yeah according to
experts that means she and Donald Trump
had sex last night that's right last
night I had to do it with that guy
that's my Melania Trump classic
Slovenian accent yeah yeah I worked hard
on that one
I'm from Slovenia I says big news from
Washington according to the Senate
president Trump's budget is dead on
arrival
yeah in other words in other words
Trump's budget is covered by Trump's
health care plan so
we were
[Applause]
very clever little bit along I got big
news out of Hollywood I call it
Hollyweird Andy I know you do oh I know
kind of a weird down that's yesterday 54
year old Tom Cruise 54 year old Tom
Cruise revealed who will be making a
sequel to Top Gun for a Top Gun sequel
yeah yeah in the new version the song
danger zone is about Tom Cruise's
triglyceride levels
all right check this out crazy story
it's been in the news I'd mention this
before but it's just insane a black man
has received a surgical transplant of a
white man's penis black man needed a
penis and they they gave him a white
man's penis yeah yeah you can tell the
transplant was effective because every
time he turns on the radio his penis
changes the station to NPR it just I
don't know what it's grabbing with right
I don't know why it has I don't know I
got one tuner is just a button you push
it maybe it's not a knob that it has to
grab on to like a so he's just doing
that is what you're saying cause more of
this kind of thing that's what I should
have gone with I was too busy working on
my Milani impression to get that just
right your so that should it yeah it
should be more of that I had a penis
reaching out and then turning her an
antique dial just a mistake cause I'm an
idiot strange story out of Cambodia in
Cambodia an actress is not allowed to
make movies because the country's
government said she's too sexy so ladies
and gentlemen now you know why I'm not
allowed to make a movie
[Applause]
you